we're here on the carpet do you remember
the carpet for the first movie how
different was that experience versus
this one
do we have one i don't know if we had
one 90 sure we did
i thought it was pretty great so no
memories of the first carpet okay well
you guys look great tonight but well
thank you thank you very much you do too
you look beautiful
we brought a couple of them did you i
was you who are your dates your kids my
daughter's right there
isn't she adorable
she made it
on the carpet it's so couture she
doesn't care i'm her dad she cares very
little about me or what i do well your
little one was on the carpet right yes
oh my god you took her on the car well i
wanted to bring her and then before i
knew it she said
well there
may be a red carpet
and she was so excited i didn't even
know that she knew about red carpets
she was posing for photos we should go
take pictures will you come take a
picture with us
the original movie
the dance sequence
how did everyone know the choreography
can you explain that and set the record
straight how did the students know um
god's gift the choreography is god's
gift yeah
oh that and yes i'll buzz in on this
answer
uh we not we usher looped in a line that
if you listen very carefully you will
hear where he goes
okay pally hi everyone do that dance
that i taught you sure fixes everything
he fixes everything he is everything he
is everything a little urscher
five now we're gonna do that dance i
taught you and i know you've been
practicing i forgive you
let's dance
[Music]
your original movie came out one time
when social media wasn't even a thing
what advice would you give the teenagers
of today about all of the social media
they're the ones who can give me all of
the advice about social media
yeah to me and people of my generation
who granted
invented tick tock um i don't understand
it okay so i think it's wonderful that
they're utilizing it in such a
productive way that gives me a job okay
i think it's tremendous okay great
we saw on social media you posted with
your man a very handsome gent is he here
tonight and how happy are you my
daughter swooped his invite and i wanted
to uh bring someone to help me take care
of her instead and he said you know what
you guys should make it a girls night
and it was actually uh largely his idea
to bring her instead of him so
what makes him the best you're glowing
right now
he's just he's just an a plus human
being
i don't know how else to put it